[Music]
our favorite cartoon for grown-ups
is full of cultural references that you
can only see if you've watched the show
several times and that's exactly what we
did so we can show you the most
interesting references in the first
season of Rick and Morty stay tuned if
you want to know who is that guy with
the rainbow suspenders if you love Rick
and Morty as much as we do don't forget
to subscribe and please give this video
a big thumbs up today we are showing you
10 rick and morty references only true
fans noticed rick and morty
did you know that the whole show is
actually based on Back to the Future at
least that's what the creator Justin
roiland
wanted to do at the beginning after all
we all had a feeling of deja vu when we
saw a mad scientist traveling in time
with a young teenager but we never
thought that all those things would
happen before the TV show that we all
know he also created an animated short
called the real adventures of doc and
Marty they did fun things while
traveling through time to save humanity
and this time it was clearly a parody of
the popular Back to the Future Justin
roiland said that the short was a way to
poke fun at the idea of getting cease
and desist letters he even wanted to
call it Back to the Future the new
official Universal Studios cartoon
featuring the new Doc Brown and Marty
McFly just to troll Universal Pictures
however the original skit was never
shown to the producers of Rick and Morty
Justin roiland didn't even want them to
see it this is why very little
connections remained except for the two
main characters whose names were changed
to avoid any problem but it is still
weird to think that our favorite cartoon
was based on one of the most popular
science fiction movies of all time hey
guys we are so excited to announce we
are producing our own
original content head over to the trendy
for the best DIYs fashion tips makeup
hacks and so much more we are sure
you're going to love it
and be sure to let us know what you
think in the comment section she loved
to hear from you see you there the theme
song you have heard the theme song at
the beginning of every episode and most
of you didn't even see two important
references in the opening credits many
fans notice that the song was similar to
the Doctor Who theme song and the
composer confirmed this on reddit
he said that he ingests and discussed
the theme song before the show had even
been written he said he wanted something
inspired by the Doctor Who theme song
and also the Farscape theme the composer
always had a special place in his heart
for the original Doctor Who theme and
its versatility
over the years he was probably happy to
see that fans noticed the similarity
when they were listening to the song and
that's not the only reference that we
noticed the opening credits were clearly
inspired by The Twilight Zone the
eyeball and the equation going across
the screen at the beginning can also be
seen in the popular TV series this other
reference is hard to notice but the
green frogs chasing our two favorite
characters through the wasteland we're a
reference to the Wheel of Time series by
Robert Jordan we didn't even start
watching the show and we already knew
that there were going to be a lot of
references this is why we paid attention
to some of the best episodes from the
first season
pilots let's start from the beginning
with the first episode pilot the first
reference was pretty obvious when we
took the time to look at the characters
in the background and mr. goldenfold's
class a guy was wearing a t-shirt with a
blue bark from the simpsons on it and if
you didn't notice him this time he also
became a reoccurring background
character in future episodes of Rick and
Morty but what we liked the most was to
see the silhouettes of many of our
favorite aliens at the beginning of the
team inside the interdimensional customs
if you pause the video and looked
closely at them you notice not only one
or two but seven famous characters there
were Tom servo crow T robot and gypsy
from Mystery Science Theater 3000 in the
middle at the right then we could see
Big Bird and mr. snuffleupagus from
Sesame Street okay there were not aliens
but we could at least say that they
looks just like one there was also the
xenomorph from alien and last but not
least we also saw the alien from the
game space and
in this team it was only the beginning
of Rick and Morty and we already knew we
could expect great things from this
cartoon if you think that you saw
something too in the first season you'll
have to keep watching this video to see
if you were right
the lawnmower dog first let's start with
the title of this episode you will
notice that many titles are actually
based on many cultural references which
gives us an idea of what this episode is
going to be about this time the
lawnmower dog was a reference to the
movie The Lawnmower Man in which a
scientist helped a mentally handicapped
a gardener become super-smart and this
is the same thing that happened in this
episode with the dog snuffles was even
able to speak with a mechanical helmet
which was a reference to the voiced
caller from the movie up this was how he
was able to say that he wanted people to
call him snowball this was a reference
to the popular book Animal Farm just
like the pig in the book snuffles was
able to speak like humans and even walk
like them with the full bodysuits the
whole story just looked really similar
to the popular George Orwell book in one
scene of the movie we could even see the
dogs playing poker which was the
reference to a famous painting and
anyone who loves Justin roiland work
will notice a reference to one of his
projects that he never really got the
chance to work on dog world that's a lot
of references to dogs but you'll have to
watch this episode to see some
references to the movie Inception
anatomy park as we said before most of
the titles were a cultural reference and
this time the whole episode was based on
Jurassic Park it became pretty obvious
when we looked at the sign but when we
think that they were inside a human body
it also makes us think of Fantastic
Voyage in the cartoon rich drink more
tea so he could enter the body of a
homeless man which was similar to what
happened in the movie but some people
think that it could also be a reference
to osmosis jones people just love going
in other people's bodies and as morty
walked through the amusement park we
could also see many references to disney
for example spleen mountain was a
reference to Splash Mountain Pirates of
the pancreas was a reference to Pirates
of the Caribbean the haunted liver was a
reference to the Haunted Mansion and the
most obvious one was probably it's a
small small intestines which was a
reference to it's a small small world
the guy dressed as a dog was also meant
to be goofy we don't know about you but
it
actually sounds kind of fun if you had
the choice would you like to go to
Disneyland or to anatomy Park
don't be shy to answer in the comment
section down below we'd love to hear
what you think meeseeks and destroy'
we'll skip em Knight Somalians because
there were not a lot of references in
this episode but you'll have to stay
tuned because there are a lot of things
that you don't want to miss in the first
season first the title of the episode
was a reference to the Metallica song
seek and destroy the song Sweet Home
Alabama was also featured in this
episode being sung by Rick himself an
important part of the story was based on
a fairy tale that we all know Jack and
the Beanstalk just like the character
Rick and Morty traveled to a fantasy
world in which they climbed a giant
Beanstalk to confront a Giants fans also
notice that the introduction of the
episode was a reference to the movie
event horizon it could be noticed with
the fringe science references and also
the visual similarities to the film
setting this next one was also really
subtle but people think that they saw
Rick dropping something that looks like
an invert NES cartridge but a more
obvious reference was the device that
they used to capture Morty's possessed
family on the ship can you guess which
movie inspired it it was the popular
Ghostbusters and we couldn't in this
episode without another cultural
reference the after credits scene was a
reference to Harvey Dent from The Dark
Knight
stay tuned for more Ric potion number 9
the creators of Rick and Morty loved to
use the cultural reference as an
inspiration for the titles of their
episodes and this time they were
inspired by the movie love potion number
9 Rick asked for a DNA sample and morty
unzipped his pants the mad scientist's
quickly stopped him and said that he
only needed a lock of his hair because
this is not Game of Thrones anyone who
watched the TV series knows that there
are a lot of scenes that are too
inappropriate for children and morty
wanted to do the same thing when he
pulled down his pants when it's not
necessary to show too much skin just
don't do it
but there's another joke that was even
more inappropriate if only you could
understand what it meant only a few
people did death shot a bunch of
Cronenberg monsters Jerry told him that
her weapon was something that he has
between his legs this was when Beth
replied that in this case he could call
her Ernest Hemmingway Jerry didn't get
the reference but they kissed anyway and
if you are still wondering what it meant
we have to tell you that Ernest
Hemingway put his weapon in his mouth we
won't give you any more details only
grown-ups should understand that one and
if you are wondering where the name of
the monsters came from it was inspired
by a Canadian filmmaker who was famous
for body horror films David Cronenberg
rixty minutes we'll skip raising gaze of
resorb to get to something even more
interesting as you can guess the title
is another cultural reference the TV
segment 60 minutes
there is another big reference that you
might have missed in the reality where
Jerry was famous all the movies he was
featured in were actually real-life
movies each time he took the place of
the character played by Tom Hanks the
slow speed police pursuit was also a
parody of OJ Simpson before his trial as
it was similar to what really happened
during the real chase in this episode
they also watched a lot of TV shows from
other dimensions and they were all based
on TV shows that are part of our
universe there was not turning a version
of Game of Thrones where Tyrion
Lannister was a tall person in a world
of short persons we could also see the
thriller music video in a world where
everyone was phones we also saw Cloud
Atlas and Saturday Night Live another
obvious cultural reference was when Rick
told Morty that he missed a preview of
his dad Citizen Kane even if you didn't
watch the movie you probably know that
it is considered to be one of the
greatest films of all time
so what Rick actually meant is that
Morty missed a preview of his dad's
masterpiece there are many other things
that we have seen the first season but
we will have to talk about something
really important before the end of the
video the guy with the rainbow
suspenders we have seen this guy in the
background in many episodes and he was
really recognizable with his rainbow
suspenders and the football on his shirt
many people have been wondering who he
was and if he could even have something
to do with the story but no matter how
much you watched the TV show you will
never see the coach for reference that's
because only those who heard the creator
of the show talking about him will
understand who he is or actually who he
was supposed to be Justin roiland was
friends with
tersh who worked on gravity falls and
Jason Ruiz who worked on murder police a
show that never aired the three guys
wanted to see the same character on all
three shows so it was the end universe
link among Rick and Morty and the two
other popular TV shows unfortunately the
two other creators didn't have the
opportunity to add the guy with the
rainbow suspenders so this reference
doesn't make any sense now but wait it
gets even more interesting there were
three Roman numerals on the shirt of the
character 18 3 & 5 Roland said that the
character on the other two shows would
have different numbers and it would make
a code but unfortunately we'll never
know what it is are there any other
references that you noticed on Rick and
Morty don't be shy to tell us what it is
in the comment section down below
and that's it 410 Rick and Morty
references only true fans noticed if you
want to see more stories like this make
sure you watch 10 inappropriate jokes in
Rick and Morty you might have missed
[Music]